All right.
Jordan Blashek, how are you?
Oh, I'm fantastic.
Thanks for having me on.
I already enjoyed so much
speaking before this
so I'm so excited for the show
and I purposely didn't ask too much
because I'm ready to hear now.
Jordan, you have such
an extraordinary life path.
From being an infantry officer,
to studying at Princeton,
Yale, and Stanford,
law degree and business degree
and I can't even grasp my mind over it.
You're writing a book
which is coming out soon,
but actually by the time this is aired
it will already be out,
talking about America
and the polarization, or hopefully
I hope there is some optimistic note.
We'll see.
And now at Schmidt Futures
and I can't wait to hear all about that.
And lastly, venture partner at J-Ventures
where I am also at.
So, this is just all wonderful.
Jordan, how do you get to go
to these three incredible institutions?
How do you get to be an infantry officer
in the US Army?
Yeah. Well, it's funny you say that.
Every time I talk to Israelis,
I feel like I am so under accomplished
because by the time
you guys even go to school,
you've already done so much in your lives
and that's true for you, too.
But yeah, I've had a great few years.
You and I have shared a lot.
I was the first associate at J-Ventures
when it was just J-Angels
and it was one of the best experiences
I've had at Stanford.
I have huge, huge shoes
to fill right now.
This is very scary.
No no no.
You have far surpassed me already.
But I guess, so my journey
started back in California.
I grew up in Los Angeles.
Son of two Jewish parents
who wanted nothing more than for me to go
to medical school, and I get to college.
I sort of, like a good Jewish boy,
decide I'm gonna go to medical school
and my junior summer,
I was working in medical clinics in India,
and just realized that I actually
didn't love the medicine side,
but I really did love being out
in austere environments
and working with local populations.
And so I decided coming out of that,
that I wanted to join the US military.
And after looking around,
I found that the Marine Corps
was the group that I really wanted
to be a part of.
They have such amazing esprit de corps.
Every Marine is so proud to be a Marine.
Wait wait. So remind me Jordan,
which of the three institutions
was your undergrad?
Oh, I went to Princeton undergrad.
So Princeton.
How common is it for somebody at Princeton
during their studies to decide
that they're going to join the US Army?
I think my year, we had about five of us
who all joined the military.
That's more than I thought.
Okay. Interesting.
Yeah. It was around 2009,
and at that point, we had watched
all these generations go off to war.
And I think there was a sense among
a lot of us, and this was true
across my officer cohort,
that there were a lot of people
who were just very inspired
over the couple years before.
And so, we were all very passionate
about serving the country.
We were very idealistic about it.
And so there was a good number who went.
And so I ended up joining
the Marines in 2009.
I went through officer training
and by the end, decided I wanted to be
an infantry officer.
So, I went to the infantry officer course
and then ended up doing two deployments.
One to the Horn of Africa
doing counter piracy
and counter terror missions.
And then another to Afghanistan,
where I was an adviser to the Afghan army.
Oh my God.
Okay. I need one short story,
I know it's impossible
to just ask for one,
but I need one story
whether it was from the officer's training
or from one of your deployments.
Something that taught you,
something that you're taking with you
until now.
That's always the fun, the most fun.
Oh, that's a great question.
I think the lesson I learned
from officer training,
especially the infantry officer course,
the Marine Corps does a fantastic job
of training young leaders.
And the one thing they want you to learn
is to operate under uncertainty.
And so, the infantry officer course
kind of from start to finish,
is just one uncertain event
after another.
They'll wake you up at three a.m.
and send you off on missions
where they won't tell you what's coming
three hours later.
And I think the value I gained from that
over time was just being very comfortable
without knowing what's coming next.
And in every job I've had since,
it's just been very valuable to know
that through persistence,
I can just figure it out
and to be able to make decisions
under uncertainty.
And the Marine Corps just did
a fantastic job for training that.
Unbelievable.
I remember I climbed Kilimanjaro
with my father and brother
about a year ago exactly,
and on the climb I read,
"Extreme Leadership"
by two people that were very high
in the ranks in the US army,
and I remember just how impressed I was
with this mindset
and obviously having gone through
a military training of my own,
I don't think it was as intense,
probably a little much less intense
than what you've experienced.
I was much more in the typing.
My finger got injured.
That was the biggest injury I had.
But that's incredible. Okay.
So, you do that.
And where do you go from there?
How do you how do you get then
to do law in Yale
and then business at Stanford?
Yeah. So around 2013, it was sort of
increasingly obvious to a lot of us
that the wars were winding down
and if the wars were winding down,
at least for me, it sort of, began to lose
a bit of its idealistic purpose. And so,
if the wars weren't gonna be there,
I decided it was time to move on.
And it didn't come from
a desire for combat,
but it came from this sense that
there was a lot of mission
and purpose when we were preparing for war
and if we weren't doing that,
it wasn't going to feel quite as visceral.
And little did I know that a year later
we'd be back at war with ISIS
but either way, I made my decision
and decided to leave.
And so I wanted to go to graduate school.
I knew that over the long term,
I wanted to do two things in my life:
I wanted to be able to engage
in the world of ideas and policy
and I also wanted to start companies.
And so I decided with four years
of the GI Bill,
that it would pay for school,
that I would try to do law and business
because law would give me that ability
to work in the world of ideas and policy
and business school would help train me
for a career in the private sector
and creating companies.
And honestly, I think
there's something about veterans
who come out of the military and feel that
the world outside the military
is so foreign.
You don't really know
what's happening out there,
so we decide to go to grad school
or to go to college.
And I've seen that through
a lot of my friends leaving the military.
That there's almost this desire
to like arm up with degrees
'cause it's going to prepare you for world afterwards.
And so I ended up doing that
and getting the two joint degrees.
I think that's so interesting.
In the Israeli military, every day you see
one of your friends getting released
because everybody is in the military
and there's always this initial shock
where you ask them on the day
that they're about to leave the base,
like how are you feeling?
Are you excited?
And almost all of them are saying,
"No, we're terrified.
We're excited that we're finished,
but we're terrified."
And then you meet them the next week
at a coffee shop in Tel Aviv,
and they're having
the time of their lives
already working on their second startup,
and the assimilation is quick
because I think
everybody goes through the experience
so they're able to talk to
a lot a lot of people
who've gone through this.
So you get your law
and your business degree,
you're also an associate at J-Ventures,
and I'd love to touch upon this book
that by the time this airs,
has already come out
because it's touching on something
that I became very passionate about,
studying with Larry Diamond
at Stanford this year,
talking about the polarization
within the United States.
How do you go then,
because you've done this in the past
just two years, right,
writing the book.
So, what drives you to go
and think critically about community
within the US and where we're at now?
Yeah and you know, so I started this while
I was at Stanford Business School
and it was also at the same time
I started working for J-Ventures
and I started working
for Eric Schmidt at Schmidt Features.
And I think to your point
before, leaving the military
I felt like I needed to go to school.
I needed to get some credentials
and arm up with more information,
but very quickly realized
that at that stage in my life,
that the best information I would get
would actually come from working
and in going out and experiencing things
and learning on the job.
And so, by the time I got to Stanford,
I focused mostly externally
and was trying to find opportunities
where I can learn the skills
I really wanted to learn.
And with J-Ventures
I got to learn about what it looks like
to do due diligence on companies
and how to think about the markets
they were moving into
and how to look at a team
and evaluate whether you want to make
a bet on this group.
With Eric Schmidt,
I learned some incredible lessons about
how to think about things at scale
or how to take ideas from good to great
or collaborate
with different groups of people.
And separately, this was around 2016,
and clearly something was happening
in the country.
There was a lot of division
and the country seemed to be convulsing
under this weird political environment,
and I decided
I wanted to see it firsthand.
So instead of learning about it
through the news or in classrooms,
I wanted to see it on the ground.
So you go and you get into a car
and you just drive.
Yeah, and the first few trips
started just for fun.
My friend and I wanted to be on the road.
And so, we took some of our breaks and
and picked a few places
we wanted to visit
and just got out on the road.
And while we're out there,
you just see the country differently.
It's big and beautiful
and everyone you meet is hospitable.
And you learn something from them.
And we also learned from each other.
And being in a car for long hours,
my friend Chris is a hippie from Berkeley,
I'm a conservative Marine,
and we had such different world views,
but over long conversations,
we were able to untangle
all these common values
that we actually had
underneath it all
even if if we were just having a debate
with friends,
we would seem to be at odds on everything.
When we were really able to give it time
and with humility,
we found that we shared
all these common values
and where we didn't,
we learned something about ourselves.
We learned what blind spots we had
or what presuppositions
we were coming to arguments with.
And so the heart of our story
ended up being the things we learned
about each other and our friendship,
and the things we learned
about the country
through the people we met.
And so the book is this argument
for what still binds us together,
despite all the political division today.
I think that is so wonderful
and it's so optimistic.
One of the incredible things
that I was so inspired by
learning this year with Larry Diamond
was this experiment in
one ... room he had
where he brought in hundreds of people
from a random group to Texas, to a hotel, and
into a venue,
and over three days
they had them converse
in a very humane way.
And all of a sudden,
what inspired me most was,
not that they changed
beliefs sometimes, but that
Democrats began seeing Republicans
as instead of enemies,
as people that they can converse with
and have some common ground with
and same vice versa.
And that, I mean that was
the hopeful message here
and that's why
I'm really really looking forward
to reading the book.
But Jordan, I want to talk
about Schmidt Futures
because one of the things
that I saw is that
you're very into impact investing.
Right?
And Eric also, all the way
back from Innovation Endeavors,
is all about investing
and looking at things
that are moving the needle.
What is impact for you
and why are you following that route?
Yeah, it's a great question.
So, for me, there are things I care about.
I care about the future of America
and I want to see it healthy.
That's a lot of where the book came from.
And I care a lot
about the future of security and creating a
more vibrant, prosperous world,
free of war,
and I think some of that that drove my desire
to go into the military.
And ultimately, I think
the ability for a free democratic society
to survive depends on progress.
We need to keep growing the pie.
If people feel like the pie is shrinking,
if people feel like we're static,
then it becomes very zero-sum
and it's very hard
for our democratic systems
to survive in that kind of world.
And so, there is this imperative
for us to drive progress,
and that's progress in the fields
of science, in technology.
It's progress in our understanding
of human rights and civil rights.
And that's what we do
at Schmidt Futures.
We look to advance scientific frontiers.
We try to advance technology's impact
on society,
and we try to advance shared prosperity
and national security.
And we've taken a sort of unique approach
and we're very lucky to have
Eric Schmidt as our founder
who believes deeply in this
and he pushes us
not to think necessarily about returns,
but to think about
the talent we're backing
and how we're transferring risk
from them to us.
And so his theory, and our theory, is that
the way to achieve progress
is to go find exceptional people
who don't have a track record yet.
And because they don't have
a track record,
others aren't really willing
to invest in them.
So venture capital firms
won't invest on the riskiest ideas
because they're not proven out
in the market yet.
Government won't invest in very high risk
research and development
because they're using taxpayer dollars.
And so these ideas are people
that don't yet have track records,
have a hard time getting the capital
to test their ideas.
And so what we do, is we try to look
for those exceptional people,
people who but for our investment,
they wouldn't be able to do
or try the thing they want to try.
And then we make bets on them,
and we give them risk capital.
We don't take any equity from it.
It is purely for the impact
they can create.
And then we try to support them
through helping build teams around them,
giving them support and mentorship,
and watching as, through teams and talent
and support, they achieve
their breakthroughs.
And, if it doesn't work, it's okay.
We'll support them again
on their next try.
And in doing so,
by transferring that risk off them to us,
we think will lead to a lot
more breakthroughs in the world.
Wow. Okay. So I mean,
the idea of a venture capital
is that you invest in, let's say,
10 companies a year.
Hopefully one of them will return 10X
and then you're balancing out
and you're able to continue doing that.
When you're giving risk capital
for no equity you're essentially,
I mean, you're just diluting
the same pie that you had initially
without putting in more.
So, it sounds like
you have to even be more risk averse
as you're going through your journey
than in traditional venture capital.
And you're betting on people.
You're betting on talent.
How do you go about doing that?
I mean, and what does that mean
to be head of talent
within Schmidt Futures?
Yeah, it's a great question.
So as head of talent, I oversee
all of our internal talent development.
So, because we want to bet on talent,
we also think internally
we have to have the best team.
I'm responsible for recruiting everyone we have.
And then we have a number
of talent programs.
So we have an entrepreneur
in residence program.
We have a Science Fellows program.
An APM program.
All of these are designed
to go find exceptional people
and channel them into certain areas
that we think are underrepresented
with that kind of talent.
So, for instance,
our Science Fellows program
is trying to produce more
interdisciplinary scientists.
We don't think there's enough of those
even though all the breakthroughs
we're gonna see in the next few decades
are gonna come
at the intersection of fields.
It's when we combine things like
computer science and biology
that you get these
interesting breakthroughs.
And so our program
is designed to do that.
Similarly, we don't think
there's enough computer scientists
in the philanthropic world.
And so our APM program is designed
to take computer scientists
and then put them
on moonshot type ventures
in the philanthropy world.
And so, I oversee
all those talent programs.
And I think the reality is,
no one has really cracked the code
on how you can rigorously
test for talent.
There's still somewhat of an art to this.
And everyone on our team
has developed their own methods
for how you find that.
And for some people,
it's they have almost
like archetypes in their head.
Just like in Hollywood,
there's specific roles in movies
that you look for.
We think in the talent world,
there are specific archetypes
that if you find them,
they're really worth betting on.
And so, there's the genius generative type
who they just see targets differently
and as a result, they're constantly
coming up with new ideas.
But that person might be terrible
at managing a team.
And so, if we can find that genius
and then pair them with
a highly talented operator,
someone who just, kind of like
the chief of staff type function
in the military,
they just know how to execute.
Then that's like a dynamo combination.
And so, a lot of what our team does
is try to find
those different archetypes
or try to find ways of testing for genius
or generative ability,
and then finding the right pair
so that you maximize
their potential impact.
Wow. Okay. That's just, I mean
to me it sounds like a dream job.
I mean sitting there and trying to think
how can we be bet on moonshot ideas
by moonshot people
that have a chance to succeed in this
and we want to join their journey
and support them,
and doing that without taking equity
and without thinking about
the capital side of things,
but embracing the talent that they have
and at the end, making a positive impact
on democracy and the country.
I think that's just incredible.
Jordan, what excites you most?
I mean, you're seeing
so many different talents,
and you're seeing
so many different projects,
you're constantly embracing
this idea of moonshot and impact investing.
What do you get most excited about?
Yeah. So, I get really excited
when I find someone
who has this incredible combination
of just raw talent,
they're very talented,
they care deeply about an issue,
and they have the specific skill set
and unique insight to go solve it.
And the reason I get so excited about that
is it's actually really rare.
It's very very rare to find someone
who just they care so much about an issue
and they've really figured out
a specific insight
into how you could solve it
and they happen
to have the right skill set
in order to do it.
And when you find that person,
it's like unlocking a code
that just can change the game.
And we found a few those
at Schmidt Futures,
and it's like the greatest joy
to find that person
and then get to help them do
whatever it is they're gonna do
because the amount of change
and impact they have
is so fast and so quick
once they get the support they need.
And so, yeah.
I get really excited about that.
There's one person in particular
who I always love to talk about.
Her name's Clem Jacoby,
who was a Google PM
and became obsessed
with the criminal justice system
because her uncle had gone to prison
multiple times.
And she had this insight
into how you can change
the criminal justice system
and she's gonna do it.
And with a very small check from us,
she's now raised over $10 million.
She's operating in all 50 states.
And she will change
the criminal justice system in the US.
And that all happened in one year.
Like in one year, she did that.
So, that's what I get excited about.
Wow. And how long is usually this process
as you're meeting new people
and as you were hearing
about their talents,
and you're actually forming
a much more meaningful relationship
about that person
not just about the how good is the market
and what are the likely returns.
You're putting that effort
that a VC might put
and you're navigating it
towards that person
and their motivation and their abilities.
So how long does that usually take you?
It varies by person
and it varies on the kind of person
we're betting on.
But someone like Clem,
it was almost immediate that we realized
like this person's special.
Let's see what she can do.
And so, often we'll start
with a smaller check
just to test them to see
with a little bit of money
what could they do.
And if they're able to get some traction
and show us that
they really have the ability to do
whatever it is they say they want to do,
then we'll go bigger on them.
And so, that first check could be within
a couple of weeks of meeting the person.
Wow. Jordan, it sounds like a dream job.
Definitely wait for my resume one day,
that I want to come and ... thank you
and learn as much as I can.
But before we leave, and I can't believe
20 minutes are almost up
I have so many more questions to ask you.
This is so bad.
I need three words from you,
and then I have one more question
that I'm gonna have to squeeze in there.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Three words to describe myself.
Yes. It's the hardest question
out of all of them.
That is very hard. Okay.
I'll go with persistent.
Freckly.
I have a lot of freckles
you might not be able to see them.
And patriotic.
I love it. I love it.
Okay. The last question
and this is actually going to be
my favorite one.
Leadership.
You've seen leadership across academia,
across military, across venture capital.
What's a common theme?
What is something that you see
that keeps coming up
no matter where you are in the world,
no matter what you do.
Because I'm guided by this idea that
leadership isn't
when you're in the boardroom.
It's not when you're in front
of your companies.
It's everywhere you walk,
every move you do,
you need to act as a leader
and you need to think of yourself
as a leader.
But so, what are common themes
that you're seeing?
Yeah to me,
the most important leadership quality
and the most consistent one
I've seen in great leaders,
is they just genuinely care
about the people under their command
or under their charge.
They just they truly love them
and they'll do anything for them.
And leaders who have that quality,
they end up putting more time and effort
into the things they do
because it comes from that place of care.
And people feel it.
You can feel when someone genuinely cares
about your well-being and your future
and the best leaders do that.
And they do it just because
that's who they are.
I love it.
Jordan, thank you very very much.
This was inspiring and I look forward
to continue learning from you
and reading your book
and maintaining this relationship.
This was wonderful.
This was, and it was my pleasure.
Thanks so much for having me.
Thank you. Take care. Bye bye.
All right. Bye.